today all ministers did a clear
agreement that there is a need for fair
taxation also of the digitalized economy
there will be also the need to
strengthen the discussion also on a
global level on the basis of g20 and
oacd what we also had to realize is that
from Germany and France there was a new
proposal coming in today
and into the discussion was also
important to have the chance today as I
would say one highlight of the Austrian
presidency that there was an important
milestone reached in the process of
constructing the banking union we were
able to endorse the results of the trial
ox on the key issues of the banking
package of risk reduction measures today
ministers confirmed the key political
elements for the deal on the banking
package the package contains important
risk reduction measures and it will make
European banking system stronger and
safer we also welcome counsels
conclusions on an anti money laundering
action plan Europe has a strongest
anti-money laundering rules in place but
recent cases in a banking sector showed
that they are not always supervised and
enforced with the same high quality
standards across the EU as the EU level
it's time to decide on further
strengthening of our economic and
monetary union from the point of view of
commission it continues to be
unacceptable that digital companies
continue to pay less than their
brick-and-mortar equivalents European
average of NPs now stands at three point
four percent it's of June 2018 and it's
down from four point six percent a year
earlier
you